in our morning rounds this morning
people diagnosed with dementia can see
their world narrow often becoming more
homebound as their conditions progress
but one program is giving patients a new
and joyous way to step back into life by
literally giving voice to both patients
and their caregivers CBS News chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook has
their story
[Music]
the music is lyrical the lyrics
uplifting
[Music]
through song and spirit these chorus
members share a particular bond I've
been living with Alzheimer's for 14
years
dementia is a tough word the giving
voice chorus a hundred and seventy
strong is composed of people with
Alzheimer's their caregiving partners
and a handful of volunteers so often
we're told what we can't do but here
it's all about what we can do Marvin
Lofquist says though he has trouble
remembering he can still think and feel
the emotions in a song like lovers
lullaby wandering seeking for the one I
use how can that not strike your hand
[Music]
lover's lullaby is one of nine original
songs commissioned by the chorus and
performed this summer at a world
premiere concert in st. Paul Minnesota
[Music]
the singers are defying conventional
wisdom that people with Alzheimer's
can't learn new things it's very very
good for my brain working
Michael Brody was diagnosed three years
ago at age 79 he's always loved to sing
at first his wife Jane wanted him to go
solo I said Michael can come but I can't
because I can't sing no if Michael goes
you need to come and there are no wrongs
in this room you know a lot of people
have had shame about Alzheimer's it
almost was something that was kind of in
the closet for a long while and I think
the chorus has been a way to bring
people out and saying hey we're just
like everybody else is there something
that happens from the music that kind of
greases the wheels yeah I think so
I have no idea how that works I just am
really glad that it's Sarah composer
Victor zoobank and poet Louisa Kasper
each lost a parent to the disease the
writing team used the singers own
stories for inspiration in every single
song we can point to the line or an
image that came from them
[Music]
to hear some thoughts that they have
come back to them in the form of a
beautiful song oh yeah
just be stunning
[Music]
they keep pulling us aside the same you
you've given us a voice
the haunting ballad of the digging was
inspired by caregiver Janet Labrecque it
was like I was in the boat with feelings
of fear and isolation
[Music]
the chorus for her is a safe harbor
because it really sums up the whole
experience of both the stormy days the
uncertainty but yet the kind of bedrock
of friendship and family and somehow
knowing it's going to be alright
[Applause]
for CBS this morning dr. Jon LaPook st.
Paul Minnesota is so powerful yeah what
a lovely project John I remember him
telling me when he was going out to do
this story and it sounded so interesting
and it's even more fascinating than I
thought it's someone just because I'm
we're doing a story with the late singer
Glen Campbell who suffered Alzheimer's
and and kept performing with it and and
the doctors were saying you know the
music has uses a different pathway in
your brain and and it can still be very
stimulating and he kept going it was
extraordinary
I mean reconnecting them reconnecting
them to their life if they could learn
and at this point in their lives it's
really remarkable yeah yeah